tu es fou
[Musique]
bonsoir je voudrais commencer par
quelques chiffres
nous avons aujourd'hui dans les théâtres
environ 100 jeunes
alors va se poser que les 100 jeunes
vont aller s'inscrire la diversité
maintenant si on voit les chiffres on va
découvrir qu'il s'y trois ans
l'équivalent fans de la licence
seulement 28 personnes vont avoir le
diplôme à vos coûts non
en fait que tu déverses étudiants
l'exemple en qu'ils ont abandonnée et
souvent même
leurs motivations sont jeunes qui ont
choisi et prendre les chemins de la
sécurité et ne pas suivre les patients
c'est là peuvent se prend 2 mais la peur
elle va jouer un rôle majeur de nos vies
elles feront prendre des décisions
importantes où j'avais de sept ans alors
que je finissais mes préparatifs pour
vignes en france je pense que vous avez
noté mon subtils accents brésiliens
j'ai un compte et mon oncle que j'allais
partie en france quand je le dis n'est
pas content pas du tout il dit pourquoi
pas restée intelligent de l'expérience
en france il les a dits côté la
compétition en au brésil ait tranché -
tracé
pourquoi tu à partir et faire face
risque
alors évidemment je n'ai pas écouté mon
oncle je la mets je pense ça peuvent
parler non six types de secours en fait
c'est qu'il ya un terreau c'est mon
oncle ce n'était pas ce que je voulais
faire de ma vie
et l'auto c'est que c'est simple et jour
des faits
il aura pu dire qu'il a beaucoup
d'opportunités en france et que j'allais
beaucoup en plomb avec vous avec la
compétition mais lui il avoue les
risques les la chance de risques
seulement écouter bien sûr nos grands de
ce monde
un temps de cela
les problèmes
et qui est beaucoup de personnes vont
les écouter
evs ont choisi en voit qui le donnait en
illusions la sécurité
ils vont planter c'est qu'on appelle les
sentiers battus
à mon avis les choses qui nous font
vibrer qui nous anime dans la vie ces
caches justement de rien eu peur est la
seule option qui vous avez su affronter
les sentiers battus ce sont des
solutions qui nous amène à vivre en vie
sain passion
ils vont parler apporter la sécurité que
les sprays
aujourd'hui en france il y à 1,5 million
des jeunes qui ne vous dis pas qu'ils
travaillent pas xom informations on les
appelle les nits parmi eux il ya des
personnes qui sont malades ou
handicapées donc son déni disposant qui
ne dépend pas d'elle ça c'est évident
mais là aussi parmi eux des personnes
qui ont choisi d'un verre jouanno c'est
la raison et souvent même parmi ceux qui
ont choisi d en faire si l'absence de
motivation et d'engagement
l'absence de motivation et d'engagement
elle va provoquer un coût économique
pour l'état
alors parmi les 12 millions dé litres en
europe et les chiens coûts de 2
milliards d'euros par semaine mais pire
que ça je crois qu il pas mieux
il navigue des personnes la nana qui
avaient des passions drève envie de
commencer le projet mis un mois c'est
tout pour finalement c'est gagné pour
moi c'est la démonstration c'est la
preuve qu'ils y auraient nos passions
faire des choix en fonction de peur
qu'une rendre malheureux mais aussi
d'engendrer un coût économique pour
l'état
vous voyez que le système scolaire nous
engage à prendre des voies dites royal
aux débouchés qui ne correspond pas
toujours match de travail
car forcément cela va clairement que des
diversité de profils et donc fils qui
est beaucoup plus important et le
chômage
maintenant je pose la question qu'est ce
que vous pensez que c'est parce si on
choisit d ignorer la voie dite royale
c'est parce que ne partagent plusieurs
choses hein comment ils ont dépassé les
purs de l'échec
ils ont suivi le patient dans mon
parcours j'ai rencontré beaucoup de
jeunes passionnés comme est un client
attend étudiants farid technologie qui
aiment les jeux vidéo lots il est en vie
des commotions projet sur sa natte en a
pas les compétences techniques pour le
faire
après la claire on développeuse qui
étudiera farc de technologie qui est
aussi passionné par le jeu vidéo
mais de son côté n'a pas les compétences
commerciales et de gestion que le faire
malheureusement matin clair pour rien
n'est jamais sans compter or ils ont
besoin l'un de l'autre pour développer
le projet ensemble
maintenant ça suffit d'imaginer comment
une personne et les manceaux comme ça
comme une atteinte claire existe nous ce
monde
les personnes qui partagent les mêmes
passions et des compétences
complémentaires
prenez jamais sans compter et développer
le projet ensemble
c'est pour ça que cela aujourd'hui parce
que j'ai décidé et que l'implication qui
peut changer ça qui peut connecter les
personnes qui partagent les mêmes
passions des prisons complémentaires ils
veulent confier le business
suffit dit que l'on compte avec votre
e-mail et votre pass sas par mot de
passe
donc ce n'est pas utilisé alors
maintenant l'important pour nous c'est
vos passions donc on revendiquer vos
patients pour moi c'est la technologie
et la science
son bric vos besoins commotion projets
d'investissement des partenaires
maintenant peut explorer votre ville en
fonction des personnes des projets
catégorie
les personnes qui sont à côté de nous
et des projets on va voir clair
maintenant pour voir ses passions
et aussi son business là pour comprendre
que ce qu'elle fait comment la fin ils
et pourquoi
pour nous les pourquoi c'est très
important
évidemment vous pouvez parler avec la
merci
en maintenant les clés en attendant ce
monde peuvent se rencontrer et
développer le projet ensemble
pour découvrir des personnes et des
projets lire les passions explorer et
développer ton projet
peut être voyage solitaire mais si vous
êtes dans un bon environnement
cela peut devenir plus amusante
efficaces rapides aujourd'hui notre
entreprise en mission qui va au delà de
vous aider à les et vos projets mais
surtout de permettre au mieux des jeunes
dans le monde qui n'ont pas accès
la rééducation que nous avons aux moyens
que nous avons bien que ceux des
patients a envie de commencer le projet
et c'est beau c'est que nous sommes là
aujourd'hui afin de les aider de les
faire vivre
je voudrais fini avec l'histoire de
l'acteur s'appelle jim carrey jim carrey
les français son père voulait aussi de
devenir comédien ma jing un acteur et
comédien
mais son père avait peur d'échouer donc
il a fait un choix disons consommateurs
il est devenu comptable pour ça qu'il
est pénalement stable alors qu'angie y
avait 12 ans et son père contre le
chômage et la famille les difficultés
giga compte qu'il a plus beaucoup de
laissant avec son père beaucoup de les
sens mais la plus importante et les 107
est question pour échouer en faisant ce
qu'ils n'aiment pas donc pourquoi pas
des lampions ceux ci connaît maintenant
c'est à vous de choisir
mais pour décédé vous allez prendre la
voie de coeur
au delà peur
merci aux brigades
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]